if you'd asked at the start of this
whole shebang who would draw crowds in
the tens of thousands few would have
answered Bernie Sanders but the 74 year
old has generated a movement in this
race and Hillary Clinton has certainly
felt the burn this campaign is about
putting Americans back to work at decent
paying jobs the self-declared Democratic
Socialist has brought a message of
income equality health care and higher
education for all and for reform to
campaign finance laws which he says a
schemer quality his supporters say many
of his positions of forced mrs. Clinton
to shift to the left on things like
opposition to the Iraq war they say he
has been the consistent progressive
voice and he's won praise for sticking
to the issues angrily dismissing the
talk of clothing hair email scammers
most notable of all is how he's
continued to raise money in small
amounts from a huge number of supporters
that winning voters beyond the white and
liberal remains a challenge as is the
case with so many in this race surging
and winning two very different things